this morning Israel's prime minister
urged European allies to support the
president's decision that follows a
series of violent protests by
Palestinians over the weekend four
people were killed and dozens hurt Seth
Doane is in Jerusalem where there are
fears the violence will continue south
good morning good morning Hamas the
Islamic group has issued ominous new
warnings about more violence to come and
new fronts have opened in this battle
beyond Israel demonstrations continued
around the world today this one in
Bangladesh in Israel police
reinforcements were deployed this
morning following the stabbing of an
Israeli security guard at a Jerusalem
bus station and street protests the
debate has been crude and while
diplomats may not be throwing stones the
divisions over president Trump's
recognition of Jerusalem are just as
clear in Brussels today Israeli Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu urged
European leaders to give a yet to be
seen us peace plan a chance Jerusalem
has been the capital of Israel for the
last 70 years I think what President
Trump has done is put facts squarely on
the table Arab League foreign ministers
over the weekend announced mr. Trump's
decision saying it pushed the region
from the violence what do you think
about President Trump's decision well he
made the right decision
the question is was the timing and the
circumstances right
veteran Israeli diplomat Ilan Pincus was
chief of staff to four foreign ministers
he worries mr. Trump's move could make
this region even more volatile the
president and some of his advisors have
been talking at length about the deal of
the century and the peace process to end
all peace processes I haven't seen that
it's like the Loch Ness peace process
the two sides do seem further apart now
and we've also now officially heard from
the White House that that meeting that
had been scheduled between Palestinian
President Mahmoud Abbas and vice
president Mike Pence has been cancelled
Nora all right Seth Doane in Jerusalem
thank you